hey caitlin hey evan did you read the
prompt for today's podcast episode
uh yes you're supposed to say
i've read it i've read it nailed it
nailed it that's kind of exactly how i
thought that that would go
yeah you were prepared for my failure i
was also prepared for your success i was
gonna cheer you on but i was also ready
with a backup i have your back caitlyn
thank you
thank you welcome back to another
episode of evan and katelyn podcast
um today we are going to be going
through a subreddit it's called
ask reddit where people ask
their fellow redditors a whole bunch of
questions and guess what
we may be very much lurkers in general
but we do browse reddit a ton we even
have our own subreddit which
we need to figure out what to do with so
but it exists it exists
um evan and katelyn yeah yeah yeah
that's a good that's a nice plug
um so caitlyn is going to be browsing
through the hot
questions ooh spicy so they're they're
like you know
for those of you guys who don't know how
reddit works um it's a user submitted
website where people um it's all user
driven content
and then people upvote it or downvote it
and
the post they get upvoted rise to the
top
and then once they get down voted go go
get you know disappear into
the nether that is that reddit can
become
um so i'm going to do the hot yeah so
hot is basically like
posts that are new that are like
accelerating really fast so the hot are
like
in the moment questions that are like
popping
and so i'm doing like the most upvoted
questions of
this month you're doing the top i'm
doing the
yeah so this is an example of what a
top question might be it might be what
are underrated websites
and what do you use them for i browse
through that question
like when it came up earlier through it
too
oh i'm gonna make note of these ooh boom
boom boom boom boom i got through like
three answers and then i was like
enough i think that i want to add
something original
to this to this question so i am going
to say easy gif
we honestly use that website oh wow
it's a great it's a great tool um you
just upload a video
file and it turns it into a gif and you
can
you know rescale it or optimize it or
whatever
also caitlyn you know those really
annoying google
images oh when they like
what's the file type is that new files
the thing uh
i don't know what it is but it annoys me
something that's something something
and you can't open it in photoshop yeah
yeah that file type i'm gonna look it up
right now apng no no web
webp it's supposedly like a billion
times better than everything it's like a
jpeg
and an mp4 and a gif it's like
everything so what are you getting at
but basically it's annoying because you
can't open it
easy gif also allows you to convert web
p's into gifs into jpegs into pngs into
whatevers
so it's it's uh it's pretty nice i'm not
sure if it's the best one but that's
what we use
here's another very handy one uh i might
get the name wrong this to that
the glue one yeah the glue one yeah
we've used that as makers we use that a
lot
what do you type in two materials like
plastic and metal with plastic and metal
plastic and wood
plastic to plastic yeah and it'll tell
you what kind of adhesive to use
it's often resin it's often resin i mean
it's like here are these alternatives if
you don't want to mess with resin but if
you really want to get the job done
resin right usually like five minute
epoxy is whatever yeah some something
like that
very handy if you're a maker or a
crafter yeah yeah and
um uh you know it's
there's so many good websites out there
but i think it's good that we stopped at
just
one each before we like the whole
podcast is just like
what's your favorite website my favorite
website is
ebonycaitlyn.com oh wow i bet you guys
didn't even know
he had a website still don't know what
we're doing with it
again um but we'll figure it out
eventually
okay i have one which foods taste better
when they're a little burnt
um oh ah
marshmallows oh that's good i like
cheese
burnt cheese quesadilla yeah oh
but that's not burnt well this is a
little burnt i think of a little burnt
is like
slightly over crisp you know like when
you get the the edge of your quesadilla
and it just gets all crispy sometimes
when i'm making tacos you know what i'll
do
is because we will like heat the
tortilla in the pan and some some butter
um what i will do sometimes is i'll
sprinkle cheese on the tortilla
open face kinda let it melt and then i
flip it cheese side
down and you let it crisp a little bit
and you can't go too long but i think
that counts burnt
burnt that's a little burnt broccoli oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah the egg is a little
cooler we actually are you can watch our
magic broccoli episode we
crisp those boys
all right so what is the you know so
it's like oh you're a programmer i have
a problem with my printer
what's the equivalent of this for your
job i think for us
now it's kind of like oh you are makers
want to fix my sink
it'll be a good it'll be a good it will
be a good episode for your youtube
channel
not calling anyone out in particular
but you know there's a lot that goes
into what makes a good youtube video
and i'm not sure if that'd be it yeah
but you know like but like
um in our past jobs we also had that
yeah you know i mean as a graphic
designer what's something that you
frequently got asked
i mean most of the stuff
like i kind of felt like it was in my
job description so it didn't get to me
the same as
like some of these other examples and
stuff um
i don't know come back to me what did
you get asked you got you got asked a
lot of stuff i mean at the same time
like
you know i was the the first engineer
brought on to our small company
and i'm just mainly talking about my
last job because i worked for huge
companies and in the huge companies
you you can't do anything that's not out
of your job description
like i honestly worked for a big company
and i felt stifled
that i couldn't expand outside of like
my
very narrow task that i was given but
then when i worked for a smaller company
as an engineer
i was like you know well you're an
engineer you can
do anything i t related or technology
related or
you know everything so i kind of got
everything added to my plate and then i
did it
because i'm a sucker i guess i don't
know
because you're helpful yeah and you want
to like see
people succeed yeah i wanted to see the
the business succeed yeah so i did take
on i.t
and everything i have i thought of my
thing
okay what's that that like i mean i
guess it's kind of in my job description
but it's sort of outside of it
powerpoints
oh yeah i became my nickname
at my job even though i was a graphic
designer powerpoint princess oh
sorry i'm sorry i was a powerpoint
princess
because like i could i could i could
protect close my eyes and pretend it was
indesign or illustrator or photoshop
and i got pretty good at making
powerpoints look like they were not made
in powerpoint i could do like fancy
animations and like non-standard fonts
and like
never used their built-in templates
so i got really good at powerpoints but
then like everybody wanted me to make a
powerpoint and like
sometimes your powerpoints are not
necessary
oh man okay do you have one or should i
go again um i have
i have one it kind of reminds me of
another asgard that i've heard and maybe
the other one's better but
what's immoral but not necessarily not
necessarily illegal
immoral but not necessarily like most of
the things i'm thinking of are illegal
like
here's a related one what's
not illegal but feels illegal um
[Music]
i'll give you an example that like i
don't do anything illegal oh no
well that doesn't mean you still know
it's illegal so here's an example of
something that's not illegal but feels
illegal
going into a grocery store and walking
out without buying anything
oh right oh yeah doesn't it feel like
you're doing something wrong
and you're like i i you kind of like i
just came for one thing and y'all didn't
have it i swear
okay you know what wood going into those
amazon stores
where you can just take anything but it
like like
so so basically you sign up with prime
and
then you walk in and your phone like
pings the store
and then the store tracks the items that
you pick up
and then you just walk out with them
there's no cashier that charges you
later
it charges you like as you walk out
that's weird
yes you just walk in grab what you want
and leave
that's very interesting that would feel
illegal to me
yeah um you know what
you know it's a weird thing i'm not
gonna necessarily say it's illegal but
like
so many things about it feel wrong like
filling out government forms i always
feel like you're doing something wrong i
kind of feel like i get like
nervous yeah because like you you should
do that right
but like um sometimes the forms are
really
poorly designed and it's like look at
form
five three six nine four b and take the
value
in field c and multiply
that by by ten divide that by two
and add ten it's like uh
you know i think that especially as we
became adults
and we had to take on a lot of that for
the first time i did feel like
i never felt like i was doing anything
illegal but i was always wondering like
did i do that right i don't know and
honestly
i'm not sure if anyone in the government
will check so who knows
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but it does make you feel like
you're doing something wrong yeah you're
like what what
it's like is
that this information is accurate like
this to the best of my knowledge but
like
are they gonna come at me for not doing
more research
what else could wtf mean um
uh well
they're falling
[Laughter]
that's way more funny to me than anyone
yes else who has not watched kung pao
yeah yeah yeah i mean i i'm here hanging
out with you
i'm gonna tailor my humor to you and i
know you
oh that's great uh mine would say
this is when um a jube is walking by
and you say whoa that's fluffy
whoa that's fluffy that's fluffy that's
a more relatable one
wow they're falling
oh that gets me so good but it's going
to be it's a quote from
a movie it's a reference to a quote it's
not a reference to a quote
it's it's uh it's an inside joke
um okay so uh this is actually something
that that i've thought of a decent
amount which
may or may not be weird it's gotten 75
000 up so i guess it's not that weird
you get teleported to the day you're
born with all the memories from your
past
life you're now an infant what do you do
this could be a whole podcast
we could write a whole story from this
um but but interestingly like
the thing i always think about it i'm
like would this be good or would this be
bad
i think it would be bad
i mean it would be good if your goal in
life is like success productivity and
success and money
because you can't help products but it
would
it would hmm well i guess
so i was going to say it would be bad
because you'd be going through
childhood without being able to enjoy
childhood but you've already had your
own childhood so i guess it would be
okay
the my main my main worry i've thought
through this scenario a whole bunch
you know we could make our families very
successful
we could help them like invest in apple
when it's just
small and like invest all your money and
like you know you can
you can optimize the system for so much
and like you know we can
you know there's a whole bunch of
inventions and trends and all these
things that we know
and we could like capitalize on you know
we would be
successful in a lot of the ways that
people measure success
but i think that we would
be loners we would not be able to make
friends
because honestly like what a
two-year-old finds interesting
or even like if you know as adults i'm
not sure would be
able to fully get back into things that
young kids
enjoy for as long as they enjoy them
we'd be super bored
like having to be in we would want to
converse with adults and adults would be
freaked out by us you know yeah
i don't know and and also the biggest
thing is like how
would i meet and date you
yeah because that's the you know all i i
can get through being a weird little kid
you know for for some of the other side
benefits that it that it does you know
like
invest early in these big companies get
you know success
so you can basically retire and then
start a youtube channel for fun
have success there too because you
already know you know all of the trends
that youtube is going to go through
you can game youtube too you know the
types of thumbnails that are gonna work
then you're gonna know
when to shift from one type of content
to another you can be the head of the
game and all these different things
but then of course you're gonna run into
issues that you don't know how to deal
with so like if you game that system
and you're successful at it then you
have like this insane fame
and you may not be equipped to deal with
the emotional burden
of having that many eyeballs on you
maybe but also it's like
i don't know it all comes down to in the
end
would i like chance
my relationship with you for anything
else and the answer is no
but if you looked at it from the um
because that that kind of makes sense in
the like would you go back in time and
change anything
but if you looked at it in the same way
that i was with like
well i wouldn't want to miss out on my
childhood
but you've already had a childhood so
we've already
dated we haven't dated our whole lives
oh like you would find like to start
dating me earlier
no no no no like i would try to
yeah like how would i like i'd go to the
same college that i went to so that i
could meet you at college
but how would i interact with you like
what if we didn't like
have the same start of the relationship
what if
you were weirded out by me because i'm
like i know you
i might be i know you i know
these stories you know it's like i
wouldn't want to change like you know we
ended up together
in this life if i could go back and
relive my life
i wouldn't risk the chance of like
messing up
our relationship the second time and not
dating you in the redo but it's
it's it's not a read it's just like
again oh you mean like
if we lived our entire full lives and
then woke up at the beginning again
i thought that's what this was saying or
oh i don't know maybe not i thought i
was saying like you could teleport
right now to the day you were born with
all the memories from your past life but
you're now an infant what do you do
yeah yeah that was an interesting one
i wouldn't i wouldn't hop in the
teleporter
yeah but if i was i would try to like
you know
i guess like like it's just saying
you're teleported
so i guess i would do what i said and
i'll try to come across as not weird
uh what's the worst place you've ever
had to spend the night
[Music]
what's the worst place or the worst
overnight experience i've ever had
either either okay so the worst
overnight experience
i had i was with my friend's family
and we were on like a day trip
like day and night trip uh like river
tubing or something like that
and i had really bad food poisoning
oh no really bad food poisoning
so i was staying at like so i was with
my friend's family
and we are staying at one of their
family friends houses or something like
that
and i was just having the worst night
ever
and i felt so embarrassed and
everything was bad and i hated it
everything was bad that's a bad time how
old were you
i know i was probably like 14 or 15.
pretty bad
but like yeah it was like i was able to
kind of deal with it some
but i feel like it probably would have
been worse if i was younger but like
still that's not that's not a fun time
it's not a fun time
yeah what about you um
i don't i don't know if i have any quite
that
no i have like like uncomfortable things
um like like the sleeping was physically
uncomfortable
but um you know like uh
when my brother was in the hospital i
like slept on a
cot or something i barely remember but
like
um i don't know i was just curious about
yours i didn't have a good answer myself
i just wanted to
know if you had one oh yeah i had one i
had them
oh one this is a different uh
different kind of worst but uh when
hurricane harvey was here
and we were just staying up the entire
night watching the news and
going outside to see how far up the
water had gotten like how many more
feet it had like gone up the driveway
yeah that was
that was rough that was rough that was
oh that was a long period of not
sleeping
yeah uh we there's a question for what
is your favorite
dead video game franchise dead is in
quotes i think that one thing
that i wish would be re-released for
modern pc systems
with multiplayer added red alert
2 would be great
i just loved that game so much when i
was younger and
i want to play it again with my brother
uh
banjo-kazooie is there still
banjo-kazooie's being released no
i don't think so they added banjo to
um uh smash
super smash bros i know that we we
booted up the n64
and we played it briefly until we killed
the n64
but it was a banjo released in 2008
i guess that's been a while for the xbox
studios yeah that's that was 12 years
ago
actually i didn't know about that though
but that was you know
during a time where i wasn't playing as
many video games banjo-kazooie
1998 98 and banjo-tooie 2 000.
so banjo-tooie was like a little bit
yeah it was good yeah yeah they were
both really good what about grunty's
revenge
it's the gameboy bands
i know there's probably a lot of video
game franchises that would be great but
red alert two is one that recently came
to mind and i wish that
it would be released yeah
um people who check the behind the
shower curtain for intruders when
using the bathroom what will you do if
someone's there one day this is silly we
don't have a shower car because we have
glass have you ever done that though
or done anything similar i've kind of
like
i've kind of gotten paranoid a few times
in my lives and i
do like think okay what would i do in
this situation like what impromptu
things could i do
or how would i deal with the situation i
think it is kind of human nature
for your mind to wander in those
directions you know we evolved
as you know hunted uh prey
for more of our past than we have been
top-tier
um people you know you know there's
that that's like the you know old part
of our brain that still
you know comes back and says hey yeah
watch out
every now and then and i think that's a
lot of a lot of people think that that's
what your dreams are
so preparing you for like scenarios you
might have to deal with
yeah like am i still streaming
that's so silly sometimes when you
describe a scary game
but you know the other night when you
woke me up because i was like
like in my sleep yeah my scary dream was
that i had gone into our living room
and we have these kind of like tallish
silvery vases
and they started chasing me and i was
running and i was trying to yell and i
couldn't which is why i started like
hyperventilating
this looks so stupid but my brain was
like
if those what if those bases chase you
you will know how to handle it so you
didn't you
but you didn't know how to handle it my
brain
you failed the test katelyn you failed
the imaginary test
um yeah but i'll all get like paranoid
thoughts like that
in my head every now and then yeah i
haven't in a long time when i was
younger
i would sometimes you know you turn on
all the lights i did used to like stuff
when i was probably like
seven or so i did like we stayed at this
one hotel
and there are a whole bunch of red led
lights everywhere
and i like developed like a like
linkage in my head that those were
eyeballs everywhere like skeleton face
eyeballs with red lights
and for a while i was like kind of
freaked out by them for a little bit
okay so time freezes for 48 hours and
you're the only thing not affected
what do you choose to do do i do
a realistic answer or do i stretch for
something that might be more
entertaining
you can give both okay realistic answer
i pick up the house
you know i i take care of all of those
things
that have been on our to-do list for a
long time
i mean if you think about it time
freezing for 48 hours
like
i guess like being practical be that
if you're a thief you could you could
definitely like take advantage of that
you know it's like
everyone else is frozen for 48 hours you
go and like take stuff
but i wouldn't want to do that yeah i
was thinking more like if i
use those 48 hours to do something that
i need to do
in my life then i'm saving 48 hours of
lifetime or like if you live near like
area 51 do you just like run in real
quick and
peek around yeah yeah it's area 51 right
yeah well i was like the aliens the
aliens
52 naruto run in there
um could we get creative with that
ah this kind of goes back to the
like i guess not really the like illegal
and immoral questions like most the
things that you think of
that someone would try to do
are mostly like illegal-ish things like
sneaking around
because everyone else is frozen or like
spying i don't really have the desire to
do that
does it freeze only humans
yeah no no it freezes everything
everything because if it didn't freeze
like it only froze humans then
yeah yeah and then 48 hours later like
chaos would erupt
i was just thinking i could go like play
with kittens update i'll be frozen
hmm 48 hours of kids things you touch
will unfreeze oh i go play with kittens
you wouldn't take me with you no you
could come okay i didn't say you you
wouldn't come with me
okay if you want to well i mean like the
problem is
we can go we are adults we can go play
with kittens whenever we want but then
we'll bring them back
yeah i know
if everyone else is frozen i can't go
through the adoption process
oh legally so and you're you'd be
breaking the rules otherwise
yeah okay then i then it will prevent me
from adopting all of them
what is the craziest butterfly effect
that has happened because of a small
decision you made
um meeting you i was going to say the
same thing it's like there are lots of
things
like and then you know i'm we're being
very self-focused with this question in
a way because like who knows like
there could have been a ton of butterfly
effects that happened because of the
video we made or because of
you know something that we did to
someone else but i'm not sure if we're
really going to see those
no so i don't know you guys let us know
if there are any butterfly
effects that we have spawned out out
into the broader world but i think
for for uh me i think the the biggest
thing are like you know
if i hadn't have gone to the the desk
and met you um and helped you fix your
computer well i almost didn't
go to the school we went to i was just
gonna go to art school
almost didn't so it was like even bigger
for me it was a very last minute switch
i wasn't even gonna apply and i was like
i'm going to art school
yeah yeah so i guess that that was a big
decision that you made so it's like that
little decision you made
ended up with us dating ended up with us
making this channel
and now a hundred million
views later oh yeah we haven't talked
about that we just hit 100 million views
100 channels
it's crazy it's a really uh
oh yes yeah it's a very hard to
comprehend
number one
i just had to have a little sound board
moment to celebrate
yeah it's it's really crazy i think like
we've been
eyeballing our sub count oh now evan's
running the uh confetti
yeah it's just for those watching the
youtube video audio listeners
please ignore the segments um yeah we've
been we've been watching like our sub
count so much like ooh when are we gonna
hit a million that's been like the goal
and then
um we knew we were getting close to 100
million views
and then just pass them and we're like
wow wow that happened fast
that's a crazy number and you know i
think that in the end
a lot of people look at the subscriber
number but the view number is what
really
matters in a lot of ways
yeah yeah views are more you know every
subscriber is very important but like
the results if you're talking about in
terms of like
measuring your actual success and
measuring your actual success on youtube
is all about views um yeah but it's it's
uh
it's interesting i mean that's that's
really cool so thank you guys
everyone who's been supporting us along
this crazy crazy journey
would you go blind for one year for 10
million dollars
no definitely not only even if it was
just for a year
yeah you wouldn't either i might
you wouldn't could make it like a stick
blind crap
oh it's not i don't know i'm not sure
it's
you know i worry that's like
minimizing what blind people go through
yeah
you know i think that i i think it's i
think it's different because like when
it's temporary
like it's it's obviously
easier in this temporary hypothetical
situation that's yeah much different
than yeah i think that the main thing is
well also where that 10 million be
coming from this is
it's coming from reddit it comes from
reddit oh everyone on reddit donates one
dollar
for the person who goes blind for a year
okay
um i still wouldn't do it i mean like
you know because because i think that
like going back to like why
we went through what we
kind of did to make our channel a
success we
didn't see friends or family much we you
know didn't sleep much we
we really put in a lot of work to make
you know this dream that we had happen
and it's because we want to work towards
the goal of like
us spending time together us having
enjoyable days together and us just like
living the best life that we can kind of
and i think that um you know
i think that if
if if you are giving up your vision for
a period of time
not saying that people who don't have
vision aren't living their best lives
because i think you can live
a very fulfilling great life without
vision but i feel like
would you want to give up that for just
money
if i was in this situation actually like
if there was someone
who was like oh uh i'm just gonna turn
off your vision
for a year and you'll get 10 million
dollars i'd be like how are you turning
back on i don't trust you
oh yeah so i probably wouldn't do it
yeah it feels good first
yeah but that is that is tough and i
think that you are caitlyn has scrolled
down far enough
in the hot ass reddit section but
there's just things with like
zero upvotes oh sorry i'd be scrolling
yeah so well hot is like it's up and
rising but it's not
you're not going to get as many good
questions you aren't going to get yeah
so all yours are going to be better i'll
take over for a little bit i'll take
over
you see until i'm getting to that you
know scraping the bottom of
the barrel yeah um so let's uh
let's do this um those of you redditers
and happy healthy fulfilling
relationships
what were the green flags do you notice
about your partner early on in your
relationship with them
well this is a little hard for us to
answer because we were friends for a
long time before
we were in a relationship so would it be
like when we first met each other's
friends
i guess when we were first considering
dating the other person what were the
green flags that were like oh
yes yes yes yes i think like
everything was just like easy and right
and
not difficult i don't
like it was like this is not stressful
it was
positive without like i don't know
there's like
zero it was that complete absence drama
negative emotions or drama and usually
when you're
starting to date someone there's like
you know there's still like some doubt
or something like oh what is he thinking
there was
fear of messing up our friendship but
that was the only like
worry i had um yeah i definitely am
i do very much consider myself in a
happy healthy fulfilling relationship
but at the same time the start of our
relationship was
abnormal yeah because we had been
friends for so long
how abnormal is it for friends for
people who are friends for that long to
date my guess is it's
not super normal not super normal yeah
probably friends for five years and not
date
yeah you know what i mean yeah that that
is strange
yeah because i think that there has to
be like circumstances making you not
date if you're compatible yeah by the
time
we were thinking about each other in a
romantic way
i already knew so much about you i
already fully trusted you
everything was great we had a just great
vibe
and everything um
so i don't know i i feel
this is kind of like a side topic that
i'm kind of branching off into
but when i first started dating you
i felt like i understood what
relationship should be like and
everything yeah like it was right
it was like you know you know feeling
and it was like but then i
but then i was thinking about it more
and i was thinking you know every
relationship has its own trajectory it
has its own
origin story and you know a lot of
relationships can get to that really
really good
place but i feel like
i felt i i sometimes feel ill-equipped
to give advice
yeah because i feel like
our situation was unique i don't know
yeah i don't know if that makes sense
yeah
yeah side tangents okay
so the average human brain is compatible
of about
2.5 million gigabytes your brain has
reached near capacity
what do you delete to free up space
um uh what do i delete
to free up space
yeah you know it's funny because like i
feel like our brains
do that anyway my brain just like
yeah there's so many things from like
being
in school or even like college and stuff
that i just don't really remember
anymore
yeah my my brain definitely has you know
like on a lot of uh
uh trash boxes on computers
it um auto deletes after 30 days it's a
setting you can choose now
that's that's what my brain has been
doing yeah it's not 30 days
is there anything that you would like oh
it's kind of weird to be like i would
consciously get rid of this memory
like even if it was a bad one because
it's kind of like the whole
uh you know erasing something out of
your past how does that affect who you
are now
i think that my i forget what we're
watching but i remember one tv show
oh that movie it was a nicholas cage
movie i would delete that
oh yeah it's already being deleted from
my brain so this
is very interesting what was that
science youtube show
that was talking about how your brain
works
i don't know was it like it was a vsauce
or something like that i'm not probably
v sauce or kurtz causation
probably one of those but but basically
i may be butchering this so you might
want to look up kurtz gazad or wikipedia
or something like this afterwards
but i'm fairly sure that how a memory
forms in your brain is it's a series of
connections
in your brain the neurons firing in a
certain pattern
and that creates a memory maybe it was a
ted talk i watched this with you
and the more it fires the stronger the
memory is
you know what i mean so like you know
you you listen to a song
and that that series of inputs from your
brain
into your mind fires repeatedly again
and again and again and
again and that's why you get a lot of
music stuck in your head
same thing if you watch movies or you
you watch a movie and you think about it
a whole bunch afterwards
you're basically training your brain to
like
write it it's kind of like um you know
how a record player works
how like there's grooves in the the
thing and the neo picks up on the
grooves
it's kind of like opposite for how your
brain works as you do the same thing
over and over again it's not kind of
like you're scratching
that data into like a permanent record
in a way and the same way it's kind of
like the same
process for forgetting it if you have
this pattern of
firing neurons in your brain that is a
memory
and that pattern doesn't fire for a long
long
long time then it just kind of
fades away yeah i think that's that's
fascinating any that you would purposely
fade away aside from that nicholas cage
movie
what was it mandy or something i think
that
i don't consciously think about things
to forget
but my brain certainly is like on top of
it
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
like you probably remember
a lot of embarrassing moments from your
life
i don't and i'm not sure if it's
something that i've ever consciously
tried to
use to forget yeah but i just don't
focus on that i don't relive it in my
head
and so just since it doesn't fire
repeatedly in my head because like i
think the reason why you might
have those memories in your head is
because they repeat yeah and you're like
what could i have done differently or
what
etcetera i just like it just leaves
me yeah do you have one or should i go
again
i already told was that next oh yes okay
okay yeah
so if life was someday proven to be a
simulation what glitch or ab
normality could you point to as a major
clue we missed
like the mandela effect in general
hmm you know like everyone remembers
berenstein bears to be like
spelled with the e i n but then if you
look up the books
it's spelled with a i that is weird i
think mandela effect is a great example
of that
and of course like deja vu yeah
those are kind of obvious answers though
i'm trying to think of anything
something more unique
tangentially have you ever watched
the show the truman show oh yeah i
watched the truman show
what would be any signs that were in the
truman show yeah have you ever thought
if i was in the truman show what would
the signs be are you a paid actor
[Laughter]
oh that laugh oh no she knows i'm on to
her
that's why she's so fabulous um no but i
i i had i had thought like okay
so like would if you if i if i'm moving
places
how would they like change the set how
would they ensure that people in a new
place
i think because we moved a lot yeah it
would be much harder for either of us to
be a truman show
contestant yeah yeah yeah but i have
thought like because
you know we in our heads we are all the
protagonists of the story in a way
and i i wonder how many people after
watching the truman show was like
what if i'm on the truman show and that
was a big
troll that was a hint they're teasing me
or like a clue someone on the inside
like wants you to be able to figure it
out
they want to free you yeah
what if it was a documentary inspired by
your life
and someone snuck it in and let you
watch it
weird
maybe that was just me
um let's see
what is something that you just cannot
understand the popularity of
hmm kids these days
um let me see we understood tick tock
pretty
yeah no i like tick tock um
i'm sure i could think of something
that's kind of like kids these days it's
like kids these days
well think of something that's like not
associated with kids
because i feel like there's a lot of
stuff where it's like oh okay that kid
show
soda i got it and i kind of understand
it in the same way
five minute craft type videos oh
yeah i i truly don't understand
how they're so popular other than just
like
facebook i don't know i guess it is kind
of like
easy to hate watch but i wonder are all
of those millions
is a strong word we don't actually like
actively
hate the companies that are profiting
from this
i do kind of object to it
in some ways you know but
yeah i i don't fully understand that
yeah i don't either
i mean some people somebody's gotta like
it
like everyone hates on it everyone's
something out there
maybe maybe i guess so
if we could only get a peek at their
analytics
all right so someone offers you a
hundred dollars per hour to watch any
movie on repeat which movie do you
choose
how is this for the rest of your life um
so at any point you can sit down
and earn a hundred dollars an hour
yeah but an hour isn't even like the
length of a movie no no so it's like you
can watch it
for 24 hours oh or whatever you know
what i mean
so it's like so it's like someone this
is an open deal at any time
you can fire up that movie and just
watch it as much as you want
to me it has to be something that is
that either has like an amazing
soundtrack
because you can also just kind of like
zone out do other stuff while you're
listening interstellar
666. that's not a movie though that's a
movie is it a movie how long is it
or it's a interstellar five five high
five
yeah so that i feel like that i don't
know if that counts because that
okay animated specifically before the
daft vote in the chat
is that a movie but it was
specifically for the discovery album
but it says a film
that count as a movie i feel like it's
kind of a loophole animated
musical science fiction film
i mean you couldn't do that but i do
feel like it's a little bit of a cheat
but it isn't and that is like one of the
best albums to listen
through all the way through yeah
we've watched it multiple times i'd
probably pick like nightmare before
christmas
but would that kill it for you no i've
already listened to it so many times
it is almost like a music it's a musical
basically it's basically a musical
now if you could listen to it in the
background
like watch it in the background no you'd
have to sit down
and watch it put hmm name over before
christmas
i could also maybe do something like
like would like planet earth count or
something like that
some like not a movie nature movie
that's not a movie though
something that you could just like just
kind of stare at
and zone out and it just turns into a
background of like
whales and deep sea creatures just like
cool goats climbing mountains and stuff
like that
i don't know am i the only person who
just like loves just chilling out with
some nature
nature films planet earth
i kind of want to watch it now i know it
sounds so chill
like if it starts raining again and we
have some spare time
so maybe like anything let's do it
let's do it let's watch some old planet
earth maybe by then there will be a new
planet earth
maybe when we're spending time with
family like in the future like over like
a holiday or something like that that'd
be a good thing to put on the back
yeah one day one day
oh man so let's see
uh what is the scariest true story
you've heard or told you have some in
your family
have you told them i think maybe at the
last halloween
yeah we did do some of the halloween so
like did you do the tiles falling off
yeah i did that one okay that was
crazy but this could also be this could
be scary isn't like ghost story or also
scary as in just like
something dangerous happening
um what's the scariest true story you've
heard or told
i mean telling stories
the scariest thing that i can tell
that's a true story of my own
is anything where i saw my life
flash in front of me like car accidents
a lot of them are cars
driving cars scary it's it's it's the
probably
risk single riskiest thing any of us
will ever do
and we all just do it casually all the
time and i i try not to ever be casual
about it because i'm
very aware of it in some ways but like
yeah yeah
you know i've been rear-ended um
i've been in other different types of
axes we don't need to go into
you know that oh remember remember oh
this is a weird thing i'm not sure if
you've ever told it
the the car fire oh yeah
that was weird what about that
we were living in our apartment complex
and there was like a parking garage
um so you would like drive up to the
floor your apartment was on
we have photos of that we do should that
be the podcast background
of the thumbnail i don't know maybe not
make sense
topic of this yeah um and
and so how were we notified
where we called the apartment in the
middle of the night
from our apartment complex manager
saying that there had been a car
fire and that our car was affected yeah
a car
next to us just spontaneously combusted
it was um
it was a fault of the the it was like a
like a manufacturing manufacturing er
error so our car was what two cars down
yeah
so there was a car that combusted the
two cars next to it
yeah the two cars next to it were
completely melted the car that combusted
was completely melted and ours was like
melted on one side
being two cars down it was so freaky and
it was such a weird thing to be called
in the middle of the night by the
apartment competition it was like 2 3
a.m and like walking out
there like they had already kind of been
taken care of like the fire department
had already left by then
but you like we were in the parking
garage it the fire head was so hot it
had eaten away at some of the concrete
it
melted like the exit sign yeah above it
like
it was weird and freaky
oh that was a freaky thing yeah that was
that was really freaky
um this is gonna be a tough one but
you're choosing a band name
and then they must include a type of
pasta what are you going to call
your band oh man okay i'm running
through pasta types in my head spaghetti
spaghetti bowtie penne rigatoni
the bow tie cats the bow tie cats that's
that's pretty good i'm trying to make
like some kind of like
dj bowtie dj booty um
i'm trying to make like a pun or a rhyme
or like
something like something like that um
what are some others
does like lasagna count ravioli
the ravioli bandits
still
um uh okay let's just name
a let's just name if we're gonna choose
our band's name
our band name right now three two one
dj sofa oh yeah i thought you meant with
pasta
oh dj softball is our dj name yeah it's
not a band name oh oh okay
a dj name is gg softboss if you didn't
know
that's also jim's dj name yeah we share
it with her
no no no we we come out on stage all at
once
and we're one of those djs we're like
it's a group effort it's a group d we're
a group dj
group teacher all of us are called dj
softboss
i mean you know we have our cat ears
already all we need are soft glo
uh soft paw mitts and we'll be good to
go
actually um this reminds me of uh
there's a restaurant
that i forget was it a breckenridge or
something
um that was called rasta pasta and it
was like rastafarian pasta
and so they would play like bob marley
and stuff and it was all pasta but it
was really good pasta
but that could be a band name rasta
pasta rastafasta yeah yeah yeah
especially if it's like the right genre
yeah that'd be great
yeah it could be reggae yeah yeah
so what movie is the best antidepressant
now for this i'll have to say there i
don't think that there's a single answer
no many answers to me i think the the
movie that's the best antidepressant
is like a childhood movie that you kind
of grew up with
that you watched a ton and like
like that you have the best like buffer
memories associated with it so it's like
think of like
a time in your life where things were
the best find a movie from that time and
re-watch that
you know because i think that's why we i
love spaceballs so much
i love kung pao and you love kung pao
like but those are movies from like a
simpler time
yeah there's but also like disney movies
are in there for me oh any disney movies
because like
anti-depressant lion king i don't know i
don't know
yeah like aladdin would yeah i was
thinking like lion king has a sad moment
yeah but um lion king might be like
aladdin
is a great one actually for me i really
like hercules
it wasn't the most popular disney movie
i love hercules i thought hercules was
great
we should do a disney tier list also
ghibli oh that would be fun
a disney tutorial people upset
i know maybe it'd be fun though it would
be controversial
oh it's not gonna be our first
controversy
how dare they rank this one over this
one but also like
uh studio ghibli movies studio i didn't
actually watch until i was an adult so i
don't have that same
association i'll take studio ghibli yeah
a lot of like so feel good
like spirited away and stuff spirit away
yeah yeah
yeah yeah spirited away also for me in
the end there are some things that are
you know like spirit away has some kind
of like scary moment like scarier
moments and stuff
like kind of creepy i love that stuff
but i love that because my
my one of my favorite movies grew up
nightmare before christmas you know like
i used to like a lot of creepy stuff and
i used to wonder if i was weird
because i liked scary things you are not
you are perfect thank you
um yeah a lot lots of suggestions there
planet earth just watching planet earth
guys just like
like witness the wonder that is the
world that we live on
okay so uh maybe one last uh
question and then we'll move it to thing
of the week
what is a small inconvenience curse
that would drive somebody insane
um uh
i think that like for me
you know you'd really have to get to
know someone
to like really fine-tune it find out
what's wrong that would drive me insane
find out what they're like pet peeve is
and
plague them with that for me no you you
you could probably guess mine so i'll
leave that for you you can reveal it
um for you it would be
everything is slightly off and
everything
like moves a little bit and everything
is just like
off like slightly out of order yeah
yeah that's i i feel like our life is
more than slightly i don't know
you've accepted you've accepted now
you've been immune
okay um i was gonna go for a general one
because that's what i've been
brainstorming
okay you mess with their cell phone
any cell phone they ever touch any cell
phone cell phone and computers
plague them with it issues plague them
okay update pop-ups inconvenience curse
that would drive someone insane
let no technology work for them ever
when they're about to save that
powerpoint oh crash it
oh when they're about to call get a call
from their their crush
your phone dies rude when they're about
to like you know
finish that level that they ground for
so
so long file gets corrupted
yeah they have to start all over again
they could never enjoy any technology
everyone around them is enjoying
technology living a good life
and they are cursed and no technology
ever works for them
they can even borrow their friend's
phone it won't work for them they give
it back to their friend
it works they are just they are the
problem cursed with technology
i think that'd be the worst plague
honestly yeah because technology is like
legit so important for life
for every single aspect of it and it's
so important and i
wish that everyone had has good
technology journeys and with good access
to everything
but that's just not how it is and but i
do think that'd be like the worst curse
yeah maybe that's too big of a curse
that's a pretty big one that's a pretty
big one
here i have one for you yeah specific to
your pet peeve
which is any time
you're having a conversation with
someone
the first half of that conversation is
them repeating what they've already told
you in the past
yes that is my pet peeve
repeated things repeated things all
right i could do it i could go a few
different directions that could be one
the other direction could be like any
time you watch any piece of content
for the first half of it it's just
repeated what you last watched
before you can get to any new content
see it's not i'm not fully
wasting time yeah oh
that'd be horrible yeah but for me i
think like my main pet peeve is like
repeated things like wasting time like
or even just like anything repeating
something again
oh having to do something again we just
filmed a a little thing
for an intro for a video and
the whole thing was blurry oh anytime
like
footage is corrupted or i don't record
things or like
anything where like that time was like
wasted
well we once recorded a whole podcast
and it wasn't recording
or it was messed up or the audio was bad
or something like that and i got
i got kind of depressed for a moment
yeah like that's that's something that
can like
throw me off yeah i don't like it
yeah it's rough but you know what those
are all
learning lessons learning opportunities
this file that you're watching right now
is being recorded in two different
places on this computer
and this computer and it's redundant
it's backed up
it's powerful yes but you know what
caitlin
i think that it's about time for the
thing of the week
do you like how i extended that sentence
so i could find the sound effects
where is it too many buttons over here
yes um do you want to do yours first
what was mine the printer oh yeah hey
um so i love 3d printing
it was probably one of the the things
that got me into
um making in some ways
like tinkering and stuff like that and
the first 3d printer i got
was probably 10 years ago
2000 no wasn't that long ago no no no uh
seven or eight seven or eight years ago
yeah the rep too
and i just loved it so much and you know
we've done some 3d printing projects on
the channel
in the past but just not not much and
one thing
about our older 3d printer is the
technology has advanced since then you
know
we've had it for a long time we've had
it since before we started youtube it
works
it still is going it's a tank but i
wanted something that was
um quieter and a little bit more
detailed so like a smaller nozzle um
capable of like fine intricate detailed
prints because what we have is kind of a
larger scale 3d printer so i got or we
got the uh
you got it so together we purchased
the um prusa mini plus um and
it arrived after a long wait and it has
been
stellar quality it's it's very nice
you know we don't do reviews on our
channel we don't you know do reviews for
content or anything like that
um but i can say i'm impressed by it
yep we've had it for a couple days now
and you've been playing yeah i've been
playing around with it i'm impressed by
the the print quality
i'm impressed with the filament um and
i'm excited to
maybe incorporate that in a in a future
uh
uh you know video but um like if we if
we don't
i'm okay with it i just like having a
little 3d printer that
you know i trust that um it's quiet that
we can run
you know so quiet uh without disrupting
our content
you know the the big one was we like
couldn't
hit like you can hear it from this room
yeah it's so
it's so loud it's just like the driver
technology has come a long way
um since 3d printers first came about
and uh
i'm i'm liking it so that's my thing of
the week yeah we're still going to use
the big boy we're just going to put a
like bigger extruder on it so we can
like print super beefy stuff
yeah yeah my thing of the week um this
is a youtube channel that's been blowing
up a lot lately so you may have heard of
the channel but it's
uh the channel is stuff made here um
some video examples well i'll
i'll i'll recommend one of my favorites
we've
um like binged a few of them but uh
his robot that cuts his hair video
and i think one of the things that's so
impressive is like
i've he would that audio be picked up i
think
yeah it might have been sorry about that
i was pulling up his channel
yeah so he made a haircutting robot he's
so
freaking thorough and put so much
time into these builds like i i was
expecting
a robot with some scissors attached to
it with a motor that would just like
um on uh some kind of rotation would
just
open and close the scissors and he would
like put it in his head that's what i
was picturing
no no no this thing has like a probe
that probes his head
and measures a certain distance away and
cuts the hair and
does that differently depending on where
it is around his head yeah and he like
programmed what haircut he wanted into
his robot
and his robot tried to give him that
haircut it has like a vacuum that like
sucks his hair up and then
snips it like it's so well done and that
is the case with every single video
of his that we have watched like man how
much do you worse
so much so much effort so much time it's
so
impressive high effort crafting yeah
high effort making
yeah really high effort it's great
though it's good
so if you want to see some awesome dry
sensitivity yeah he's got a great like
dry
sense of humor yeah um you know he
there's some content you watch because
the personality is like very
like like bubbly and big and in your
face and then there's
some where it's like more chill and he's
definitely more chill but like the humor
is so great because it's so like subtle
and dry
it's good it's really good yeah so great
channel
um stuff made here he's been blowing up
so again you guys
might recognize the name it's so crazy
he has 18 videos
i know he started eight months ago it
was the first video
yeah he's at 1.82 million subs yeah but
like the videos are so good
but it's like oops it's like oops all
bangers yeah oops all bangers
but it's not really oops all day it's
very intentionally
all bangers very intentionally all
bangers
yeah yeah so it's it's interesting um
but
that takes us to the end of today's
episode thank you guys so much for
hanging out with us today we really
appreciate it
i hope you're having a great day um as
always we like to
plug this little prank that we have
going on we're trying to
to get our shows um we're trying to get
our podcast up in whatever
podcast ranking system you guys might be
listening to it on
and you can do that by rating this show
highly
so it goes up in the charts so people
will listen to it and they're like what
who are these people and then we're like
pop up a prank
is it is it a good prank no i don't know
one day
we're just gonna get a review saying
like what the heck
and then we'll know we have succeeded
hi guys thanks so much again and look
forward to seeing you in the next
episode
[Music]
bye
you